Okay, remember to go to the members only site to see any announcements and any changes. We don't have a direct link to the zoom call. So that's a change.
If you've already registered the benefit of registering as you get the reminder.
Please send in the cheek swab request form either online or print it along with your cheek swab. If you send it a cheek swab, so you're, I know what it is that you're requesting.
Everything else is not new there.
All right, so let's jump into the questions. Have you heard of the natural viral therapy called rigveer info is at rigveer.com. I suggest everybody go and look at that.
Rigveer is like at Epley's toxins that I wrote about in my book. It's actually giving a
mixture of different viral toxins to stimulate and immune response.
It can be very beneficial for a lot of different cancers.
Says the person wrote the protocols administered here in the states by a doctor in Minneapolis.
So I don't know of that doctor. I do know that this doctor is got to be tried to probably try to fly under the radar or he's going to end up getting cited by the Minnesota board.
So please be praying for this guy who's trying to do some good for people. So it is in injectable.
And what does is the stimulates of infection.
And which stimulates an immune response. No different than what we've been saying for years and years that it can actually be good for a patient with cancer to get an infection to get a cold to get a strap to get a
something like that. That's going to stimulate an immune response. Of course, you know, that's within reason. It doesn't make any sense. If a person is super, super ill and, you know, is, you know, caquexic and, you know, doesn't have the strength to administer an infection or if they're
going to get a cold or when you get a strap infection or when you encounter somebody at work that has a cold or a strap and you, you know, viruses and bacteria are ubiquitous. They're everywhere. You go everywhere. So this is the whole foolishness of this whole 2020 thing that you're going to wear a mask and not
to have a virus exposure. Just if you're wearing a mask that you're protected yourself from a virus or even a bacteria, you are uninformed, let's say.
So you are going to be exposed to things and that is what builds your immune system. So what's a strong immune system?
Why should you have your kids go play in the dirt? Because when they're exposed to different pathogens that are fairly harmless pathogens, your body then has to respond to those pathogens by stimulating the immune response.
And if you fire a TH1 and then a TH2 B cell response, you'll develop antibodies to those pathogens and that's the definition of a quote unquote strong immune system. I have a strong immune system. What does that mean? That means I have a lot of circulated antibodies against a lot of different pathogens. That's the definition of a strong immune system.
So the more that you can expose yourself to different pathogens that aren't going to kill you and your body can fire a TH1 response, which is a natural killer cell response and then fire a TH2 response, which is your B cell response where you make antibodies and you make antibodies to that pathogen.
Now you have circulated antibodies to that pathogen and that's really what you want. Well, natural rig beer therapy is just that you're firing an immune response, it's giving you a pathogen so you fire an immune response.
Not an uppermost pathogen to make you sick, but just enough to make you fire an immune response. So that's the idea of that.
Now it was Ebley's toxins. This guy created it back in the 1950s, I believe, and he was riled as a, you know, a heretic to the medical profession and all this stuff was just horrible.
So now they're trying to do it again. This is not made in the United States. This is a drug so we can't administer it in our clinic.
Okay, this person is writing about their caretaker of a person. So this is why it's written in the third person.
Lisa is concerned and not sure about the growth in her neck, her hospice, there's told her that it's from the steroids, but she's worried.
Should I send a photo? Yes, you could send a photo with an email and we should do another cheek swab. So that's what would be the appropriate thing. So it's always good if there's something going on physically that you want me to see.
If you're doing a cheek swab, then send that just like tests. Okay, you got some blood tests back. I'm not going to interpret your blood tests, but send me the blood work with your cheek swab stuff.
So send that to me, send it in the colors clinic or you can send it at labs at colors clinic. So yes, send it a photo, send in your cheek swab.
Also, do you recommend doing a cheek swab? Yes, do that. She's been able to do had been able to do coffee animals until a week ago, but now she needs help.
And it's so very painful to get up and down from bed or recliner, et cetera.
And I haven't heard any of the disc and I am very limited to help her.
I have been assisted until illness and injury prevented me from helping. What are you what alternative is we have to give it to animals. So first of all, I would look on the member site and look at the easy peasy way of doing a coffee animal.
So that doesn't require you to lay down, you can stand up in the shower and do the animal in the shower and step out and use the toilet.
So look at the easy peasy way to doing a coffee animal, if you're going to do coffee animals now certainly if it's too difficult physically to do a coffee animal that you can do castoral packs over the liver or just heat packs over the liver can be beneficial as well.
So, you know, don't cause an injury trying to do a coffee animal.
How often do you recommend using the PEMF machine? So if you have a PEMF machine, I would say once or twice a day. I think this is supposed to say more than two times per day.
I would say no, I would say once or twice a day with the PEMF machine.
Are there any natural supplements that could help with pain?
Look back at some of the other past Zoom calls, but your best natural supplements that are going to be for paid is going to be CBD, too.
Blue Turic, which is your curcumin.
And then all your flavonoids, which will be your white pillow, willobark, your Boswellia, your green tea extract, your Resveratrol, things that are in our product called the clear inflamed product.
The clear inflamed has really all those all those things your number one natural thing for paid is going to be THC, but a lot of people don't make don't like the way THC makes them feel because that's the active component of marijuana.
But I return to normal stature with this treatment.
I'm not sure what you mean by normal stature. Can you heal by doing everything you're doing? Obviously, God's in charge of your healing. It's our responsibility to do everything you possibly can to help yourself.
I know that the coffee edemas are often the best way to detox our Castro packs the second best way to detox or foot baths, so understand the seven phases of detox so Castro packs coffee edemas are working basically stimulating your parasympathetics and stimulated your liver to help with detox.
I can help with detoxification pathways, coffee edemas are helping with the gut as well, so both of those are beneficial.
There's other things to like sonas can be really good or like I said, just a hot pack over the liver can be really beneficial.
Anything that you can be doing to help you with detoxification, and I recommend that you look on the seven phases of detox remember all of our members have access to all of our courses.
This is the course I'm talking about right here at the seven phases of detox course free access to that using the same log in that you have with log in into the member site, so make sure you utilize that that goes over all the different phases of detoxification and how you want to support those and yes, this person should do another cheek swam make sure you said in a picture of that spot that you were talking about.
A couple of weeks ago someone in the zoom asked if you had heard of Dr. Gil Letterman with radio surgery in New York, did you get a chance to look into him and if so what might be your thoughts about him.
I did not all I would see if I looked into him would be the same thing that you would see you'd see a website you'd see some information.
That doesn't really give you you know any data about his patients and you'd have to call them directly and get a feel for them and I can't call and making a point with him to to do that that's something you're going to have to do if you want to move forward there's really no way for me to gain any more knowledge about a practitioner.
Then there is for you to do that and it's actually would be easier for you to do that as a potential patient because they're not going to talk to another practitioner so I don't really have a way to answer this question.
I don't have a really a way to do that.
Thank you for the cheek swab information.
I stopped taking my essay acting capsules a couple weeks ago getting kidney pain when taking them do you suggest that I start with the tea that you have instead of the capsules if I recommended the tea then yes if I didn't recommend the tea.
Then no I wouldn't but if I did recommend the tea that I would say yes i'm not the essay acting is a blend of herbs.
So there are essay acting capsules you can get those herbs in a capsule to but I think one of the key benefits of the tea was the fact that it was a tea and you were sipping it what you're supposed to sip it for a half an hour that's the proper way to take essay acting on a fairly empty stomach you make put the tea in a cup add hot water and you sip it like a tea for half an hour.
I'm not sure that you know it makes that big of a difference but certainly that's why we have most of you doing the shake because I think there is a benefit in the dorm should rate in taking it that way so it's not across the board with everything so don't quote me completely on that but I that is the way that you're supposed to be taking essay so I try to stick we don't carry the capsules for that reason.
We only carry the liquid also we had our point with the oncologist today and shared with him that we are going to discontinue the medication he took it very well but had to add that some hearty cells deliver resistance to therapy and if I have to go back on treatment it may not work.
Is this a scare well you know you could say that literally about anything well if you have to go back on treatment it may not work well if you stay on this it may not work either so I mean there's no way he doesn't have a crystal ball to know what's right for you you have to in order why so you know you have to pray about what you want to do and you feel you do what you feel like what god is leading you to do and don't let anybody scare you either way don't let a natural doctor scare you that.
You know taking this stuff is going to kill you that's that's why I just think that that's so immoral you know either way doing that you see the fear tactics I just think is immoral.
Also said we can't go by tuber markers well I would agree that you don't go by anything specifically you go by a lot of things so remember we've said over and over that you don't.
Judge your progression or regression of your your cancer based upon you know one test or even two tests or even any objective tests you have to guide it with with you know again with prayer and which way God is leading you and you know you factor in your recall to use wisdom so you do factor in what am I blood work look like what am I.
A pet scan look like what is my you know any other scans that I'm doing and well how am I feeling and then you make that decision based upon you know factory knows all about taking it to God and prayer so.
I'll soon do you suggest to have markers and other blood work drawing well you know doing blood markers and blood work is not you know real expensive so.
We have some people doing every month so some people do every other month so whatever you feel comfortable with so it's it's got to be how you feel comfortable but.
In a you know just try to take you know the conventional wisdom that's out there I'd say every 30 to 60 days make sense to me if I was in a greater state of remission I'd go longer but.
You know you're talking to somebody who hasn't had their blood work done or any test done for well over a year so.
You know should I.
Who you ask you asking me no I'm not going to I don't need to I'm doing fine so I don't rely on those objective things is that foolishness well turns out who you ask so.
But it's my body and I have to answer to God with those decisions so but I'm telling that's telling you that's what you should do so.
In regards to histamines one of my breast cancer drivers is histamine I avoid histamine foods as much as possible I understand that left open.
Grow histamines I would say they grow them but the longer food the older food is the greater amount of histamine to this doesn't happen with all leftovers or just that are even foods that are not histamine foods.
Good question well there's some histamines in pretty much everything so the older the food is even if it's a even if it's a very low histamine food it will have more.
It's still probably not anything to be concerned about so if it's a low histamine food and it's a leftover I would not be concerned with it at all don't don't even consider that don't even take that into your account.
This is a scary example I cut up some great cabbage purple cabbage will belong in advance for a week is it growing histamines I would say probably not so you can look at histamine you can Google food histamine lists and you can see 10 lists and there they can have a great difference between those 10 lists that the reason is is that if you sent these things to a lab to test for histamines it would be all over the board so let's say I have.
I had sauerkraut and this and and then we had another thing of sauerkraut we sent it to the lab different readings depends on the age of the sauerkraut and sauerkraut has histamines in it and and everything and so it's it just could be very all over the board so.
That's why we say what I've written about histamines and my videos about histamines it's not about eliminated histamines it's about just reducing them so okay nuts have histamines that means you shouldn't have any nuts no but maybe don't have just a bowl full of nuts for a snack you know so strawberries have histamines in it grapes don't have as many histamines so.
Maybe just don't have a bowl full of strawberries doesn't mean you can't throw some strawberries and you're smoothie you're just trying to reduce your amount of histamines without going crazy about it for the Navarro test the acetone says to 100% acetone mine says it has 100% acetone that lists one other ingredient listed no you can still use this acetone for the Navarro test now I will say.
I will ask your opinion on whether the your Navarro test is accepted because the last I heard they're not accepted the Navarro test so if they're now accepted the Navarro test that would be a great thing so let us know if they're accepted the Navarro test at my last lab draw I had my cholesterol my thyroid my cancer to remarkers and so on tested.
I am due for another one done on March 10th I'm wondering if I should have all these same things tested again I'm also struggling with hot flashes at night sweats let's talk about that second so back to this question should I have all these things tested again all why not unless you know cost is a factor for you then I would just go and test them all so yes I would just do them all.
Also struggling with hot flashes at night sweats so hot flashes at night sweats really could they be a function of thyroid maybe hot flashes at night sweats are going to be more a function of your estrogen and progesterone
hormones not as much with your thyroid so if you want to get some more insight into that you really need to do a Dutch test and you can order that right on our website this is an acronym for a dried urine hormone test and this is the best and really the only way to really test all your hormones.
So we do a Dutch complete precision labs and I think that's the most accurate and researched a lab out there that's performing the Dutch test really gives you a really nice breakdown of all your estrogen progesterone metabolites I've heard that you refer to adaptogens and wonder what exactly to order.
Maybe if you're not going to do the Dutch test then it'd be good to do another cheek swap test to see what adaptogens would be best for you unless you want to just try some multiple adaptogens in the store probably for hot flashes and having them at night if you're just going to give a product to try I would try the court of clear and take that before you go to bed.
Still reviewing my genetic info one supplement histamine scavenger is needed but I also see histoclear and natural clear hist which one do I take so histamine scavenger is the one that I would take so this is the the one that I would take the histamine scavenger is and it's it's our private label it's called clear histamine scavenger
it is I think the better so let's let's define these histamine scavenger is a product that will help pull histamines out of your body natural clear hist is another product that will help pull histamines out of your body
totally different than histoclear so these two here histic clear histamine scavenger and natural clear hist are just two products that have a different components that that's why we carry them both that's why private label them both because some people will do really well with the natural clear hist and some people will do really well with the clear histamine scavenger
and the reason why I'm recommending this one is a greater percentage of the population do well with this blend of nutrients that in the clear histamine scavenger they're different they're some crossover but they're very different the histoclear is totally different histoclear is the DAO enzyme that breaks down histamine in the gut
neither one of these have the DAO enzyme so the histoclear the only ones that we have with the DAO enzyme well we have multiple but the histoclear and the ABP1 assist is also has the DAO enzyme so why would you why would you prefer a DAO enzyme product
over one that will pull histamine out of the tissues well if your main inflammation is in the gut because of histamines then you could use a DAO enzyme product
we have some people that have mast cell syndrome where they have severe histamine issues they really need to use both so they need to use histoclear the DAO enzyme or ABP1 assist with each meal and then they take the clear histamine scavenger
and some even take the natural clear hist too as well between meals to help pull you absorb that and you help pull that out of the tissue you really don't absorb the DAO enzyme it's really working in the gut so there's two different completely different products
so I would take the clear histamine scavenger by vitamin A is low so well actually we don't know if your vitamin A is low based upon your genetics but you have a gene that helps you utilize A and that you have defects on and then I recommended vitamin A so this is the product that I'd recommend for a I told you last week that I was going to tell you which one it is an email you apologize because I forgot
it's a designs for health product hypo e-molso A I can't remember how much is about 30 bucks but you only want to take a couple drops it's a very concentrated product and you only want to start with taking like two or three drops not drop or false drops so this whole bottle is going to last you you know all up an entire year or more so just two or three drops per day of this
because I originally suggested the 80k and that's usually good for everybody but I know you have issues with D and your D levels were already really high so this one does not have D at it this is just the A and it's very concentrated
okay no your chat questions do supplements and mainly supplement causing less appetite is that normal because I'm losing weight
I don't know I don't think the supplements are necessarily causing it maybe they are just you eat because you know you have to eat so just eat any how does try to really push through that it reference the question about losing weight at times by stomach hurts et cetera
maybe detoxine trying to make sure it's not my cancer in the progression of the lymphoma yes make try doing some castro oil packs over your stomach area to that might be really helpful too
so if you don't know how to do like when I say castro oil packs or coffee edemas there's information on the coffee edemas but castro packs look up in the blog there's a blog on castro oil packs I'm sure so look up in there so with directions on doing that
as far as sc acting you stated to sip it in hot water for 30 minutes it also over 30 minutes turns cold soon after it's heated so this cannot be added to daily smoothie correct with the other things yeah it's best not I mean you can I mean the argument that people have is 26 is just an herb like what all the other stuff I'm taking why can't I just put it my smoothie and believe me I've had people over the years just do that
was there any harm in that I don't know it's just that that that Renee Cassie the house she told people to take it how she learned from the giveaway chief was to put it in the hot water and sip it for 30 minutes put it in a little one of those insulated cups if you have to keep it warm
I'm not sure that you know at the temperature change over 30 minutes is a big deal I don't think so so Lisa has lost about four inches in height I had not seen her because of my injury it was shocked at how much she showed
so if a person has lost height what would cause a person to lose height well it can be just because of their posture so it appears that they've lost height but if they're standing up perfectly straight
that you measure them over time and they're losing height it has to be because of one of two things we can lose height as we age because the inhibition of our vertebral discs decreases so there's fluid in the discs between the vertebrae and we lose fluid over time as we age so we will lose height
that's a total of maybe an inch inch and a half maybe two inches if you're 85 years old you'll lose two inches in height but if you've lost like four inches in height pretty guaranteed you have a pathological fracture of a vertebrae
that means a vertebrae has fractured the body of the vertebrae which gives the height so if you looked at a picture of a vertebrae the the the square part of the vertebrae is is what's the weight buried portion of the vertebrae that's what's giving the height of the vertebrae a pathological fracture that vertebrae could just like crush down
so if the person has metastasis to a bone and the person has cancer with metastasis to the spine it's not uncommon to have a pathological fracture of the spine and you will lose height
also do you use hoviopathy yes we use hoviopathy all the time also she has a growth on her chest I missed the answer I said this first nurses think it's from the steroids but she's afraid it's the cancer coming around to the front what do you think my answer to that was send a picture in with it with her cheek swabs so we can look at that
I know you have designed this specifically for leases sickness because her cancer is considered breast cancer that metastasis to the bone how do you classify this for treatment so when when you have cancer that metastasis to someplace else it's still breast cancer so if I have breast cancer and it's metastasis to the bone it's not now bone cancer it's still breast cancer that's in the bone
so if it metastasis to the liver it's not liver cancer it's still breast cancer that's metastasis to the liver so you're still you're still treated as breast cancer even an oncologist is still treated as breast cancer they're not giving you a liver cancer drug now they're still treating the breast cancer so
yes I hope that helps so and you know you're just getting caught up as her caregiver make sure you go on the full membership site and you spend some time looking at that look at some of the past
Zoom calls we have seven or years full of Zoom calls that you could spend your entire life listening to but do we do have 900 blog pages that if you're searching for it
that if you're searching for something specifically on any of the sites any of the site pages you see that little eye glass thing that you can click on and you can search for a topic
okay any other questions I gave her this is a homeopath for a joint pain in health last night because she has been in a much pain so for those who don't know homeopathy you can use homeopathy especially in today's age where you could look up the homeopath for specific things
and you could actually get yourself a homeopathic kit that has different homeopaths for different conditions like this person being Lisa's caregiver gave her this homeopath
and she must have just looked it up or maybe she has some education in homeopathy but she looked up that homeopath this would be good for joint pain it can really help my daughters give my grandkids homeopaths
all the time when they're teeny there's a specific homeopath blend for a teeny there's a specific homeopath blend for helping with sleep and there's different homeopath blends for colds and things and things like that
it's really really big in the you know healthy moms community which my daughters are very active and they use homeopathy all the time for for different aches and pains
so when you talk about you know using you know something for you could always try homeopathy for that as well the downside is sometimes nothing seems to work
but it you know it is it can be remarkable so some people say it doesn't make any sense homeopathy doesn't work
it even works out a little baby who is not going to have any you know idea of what they're taking there's you can't tell me that it doesn't work so
cell salts would cell salts be okay to take in the morning routine yes so cell salts is another homeopathic remedy that's fine to take as well
but nothing that we do nothing you're doing with the rife goes against anything you're doing homeopathically now we technically the rife having really getting down to it is a homeopathic treatment because you've seen frequencies
that's a homeopathy is it's the frequency of something that's the argument against standard standards of care have against homeopathy is if you take that homeopathic substance and you send it to a biochemistry lab you won't find any
so if you have let's say arnica homeopathy you won't find any article in that substance once the frequency of article that's in that
and that's how it actually works and it works on the basis of likes your likes so it can be a very beneficial addition to help with symptom patterns and such and
immune stimulation things too so good then to add this homeopathy all right well we'll say goodbye for another week make sure you get your questions said did
on the member site I think somebody said did a question on the email now that I just said that and that that's why you can't email questions it I'm sorry they will just get buried I'm not kidding I get 150 emails a day so I will not remember to get them into this you've got to send your questions in
only on the the member site so please don't email any questions in or you'll be mad at me I don't want you to be mad at me
all right know that I'm praying for you guys always I love you all and I will see you guys next week bye bye